when our yearbooks were being signed a
lot of the girls
would sign you're going to be the best
dad one day and this is like best dad
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
uh a girl who's still kind of trying to
figure out what to do with her hair
elise morales and with us today we have
such a funny comedian and actor one of
the hosts of the minivan men podcast
right here on the all things comedy
network but before all of that
he was a graduate of redwood high school
it's about gibrani
hi elise how are you actually the
minivan man is no longer happening
uh my podcast now is called back to
school with maz
jobrani so oh wow you just gave me an
intro from 10 years ago so my high
school self
and my previous podcast self
cool well um that's you know
that's something that needs to be
addressed on your wikipedia page
and there you go you know wikipedia
is such a disaster i i
i'm aware of of that because i've tried
to change things on my wikipedia page
and they've told me they don't trust me
um yeah it's it's a weird thing so you
can't get on there to be like
actually i have another podcast and it's
this one
i don't even know i'm gonna have someone
reach out to them i honestly had some
other information on there about me and
i'm trying to get it off and they kept
saying no this is this is
on here because it's it's been proven or
whatever and i said i'm the guy i'm
it's me i had like my manager my agent i
had my brother i had everybody try to
reach out to them and they wouldn't
believe us they would believe the public
more than they would believe
the actual source well
um i don't have a wikipedia page
so you know at least i'm better for it
at least you've got one or maybe i'm
better for it um
so redwood high school before we before
we dive into everything
um what is this a public or a private
high school
redwood is a public high school and as a
matter of fact they were recently in the
news
unfortunately because something happened
where
someone there was posting i think
like nazi or ants anti-semitic
stuff online or somewhere and i'm going
oh no i'm going that
that was my school what are you doing
you're not supposed to do that and so uh
yeah and but also it's where robin
williams went to high school for a
little while
oh okay so okay you're obviously
like you're uh in your comedy you talk
about politics
was teenage master bonnie
interested in all of that stuff or
teenage moths
was not as interested in this so teenage
moth
was um really into sports
i still exercise but i but i i
follow sports now um kind of
peripherally
like i'll turn it on for
just my kind of brain dead watching um
or if there's a big game going on a
watch but back then i was really into
the players and who was who and my team
and all that stuff so
so i wasn't into politics as much
although i will say again
being an immigrant especially of iranian
descent i was born in iran i grew up in
america
i don't know how other immigrants are
like nigerian indian
chinese those those immigrants from
those places but
the iranian community seems to be
pretty politically uh minded
and the reason being that we left our
mother country because of a revolution i
was only six years old i didn't know
much
but i think that that
instilled this sense of politics and
being aware of politics for people
from my background so i know that my
father would read the paper all the time
um i think that they were they were they
weren't a political family where they
were writing op-eds or anything but they
just
knew what was going on and your typical
iranian in this world
in america for sure when i run into an
iranian
american versus um like an american
who's been here for several generations
i will see that the iranian american
will tend to be
more versed in politics
than someone because i think in america
we get
you know we get distracted with all the
stuff we've had for the for
200 and something years we've had
relative peace now yes we have protests
we have um
you know coronavirus right now it's
probably more heightened than it's been
in a long time but maybe during vietnam
it was heightened maybe during the civil
rights movement was heightened but
we have not gotten to the point of
having a revolution
yeah since the revolution the revolution
yeah so when you're in a country where
there's a revolution and then this other
government takes over
and and they're oppressive and so then
you kind of are
mentally in that political world and so
i think that i found
my politics in college actually
yeah i mean it's it's very interesting
so
it's a time when you're when you're
growing up um
was there a large iranian community
around you
or um like was your group of friends
other iranian kids your age
it was very different so i grew up in
northern california marine county
and up there there was a community of
iranians
and i think mostly our parents probably
all knew each other
um but a lot of my closest friends were
you know i had like maybe two or three
iranian friends and then i had
that i'd met through my parents
they're they were the kids of my parents
friends however
some of them i went to school with so we
became friends but i also a lot of my
friends were just
white dudes i had one black friend uh
i had a couple of asian friends i mean
it was
it was a little more it was not as
focused on iran as a matter of fact when
i was a kid i used to kind of be a
little embarrassed
of my iranian parents so when they would
show up at school
i was like oh my god here they come you
know they had accents they
felt like they dressed differently they
drove
like you know high-end cars and it was
just embarrassing to me so i was just
trying to lay low
be one of the other kids um it's funny
that them having a high-end
car was also one of the things
well it's funny because marin county
where i grew up is actually a very
wealthy county marine county
was i mean tibron is just a lot of rich
people but i i do a joke about in my
stand up i say
you know my dad actually my dad had been
a
successful businessman in iran and when
he came to america he was lucky enough
to be able to
bring a lot of his money with him now
later on he went on and
lost all that money in bad real estate
investments but when he first came out
and he had the money
my father was very generous and he kind
of reminds me of the
godfather character the don corleone
character and the godfather
yes he helped all of his friends
whenever he could so
if a friend had something that they
couldn't afford anymore my father would
just take it off their hands and pay him
for it so he ended up buying a
rolls-royce from a friend of his
now this is when i must have been in the
fifth or sixth grade i don't know what
grade i was in but
elementary school my father's driving me
home to school
in a silver shadow rolls royce
and it was so embarrassing because i'm
thinking to myself oh my god they
already say you're
like you own oil wells and all this
other stuff you were coming with i
literally i would duck in the back of
the car
to not be seen and then like get out as
quickly as i could
because the other kids whose parents
were also well off
but since it was marin county it would
be a doctor driving a volvo
or you know a ceo driving a saab
you know yeah i mean it was it was just
they weren't as ostentatious as my
parents
let's pull up we actually have that
photo of we have a photo of you
in your football uniform you mentioned
sports
what was your social situation like were
you a true jock
at this time or what gosh i think i had
a little bit of everything
first of all it's funny because whenever
i post these pictures everyone's like oh
my god you had hair and it's crazy to
see that
thick of hair on me and you know i was
just happy
gorgeous hair and also i had eyebrows my
eyebrows have thinned out i don't know
what's going on
i am i am slowly um
disappearing with all my follicles are
going away yeah people get those
eyebrows tattooed on their face now
i know i should go get a tattoo maybe i
don't know we'll see
also the nose is funny because the nose
grew and that was i was very
self-conscious of that nose and i think
my dad might have been said at some
point listen to my son if you want at
some point we get a nose job or
something i was like i don't want to not
stop that's
weird that's so interesting
did it consume a lot of your time
worrying about your nose because i
worried about my nose growing up too
listen i was self-conscious of a lot of
stuff because i also had like a the
slightest i mean you see i'm pretty
i'm pretty fit but i had the slightest
kind of belly
around like at the bottom of my belly so
when we go
swimming sometimes i was you know with
all the other kids i was
i was just too embarrassed to take off
my shirt even though
i was pretty thin i was just i know it's
so crazy to look you're like you're such
a you're so skinny and small in this
like i can't even imagine
but yeah but you know that's what it is
i mean i think
that's the difficulty because now being
a parent with my son now is 12
my daughter's nine and you read about
all these kids in high school and
how you know conscious they are of the
way they look and all that stuff and
it's interesting because i've read about
the development of the brain
and their brain is not developed enough
the amygdala is not developed enough the
to
to really process what the the
objectivity that you need
to be able to sit there because as an
adult you can go there and say kids i
know some of you going through this and
then you feel
self uh you know you're insecure about
your your your
looks and your your friends and other
but don't worry it's all going to be
fine this is going to go
and to them they're like no you don't
understand this is my ev this is my
world
every single moment every day but on the
back and
i can sit here and go what was i who
cared about the nose i mean i was a good
kid look i'm exercising i'm fine who
cares about the little belly take off
your shirt and show your belly
you're you're a kid you're fine yeah
okay so
if you had to rank like the top things
that were consuming
your your brain power at this time in
your life
what were like moz's top three
well first of all just to be clear like
i my sport was soccer but this is
freshman year and
i think i decided to kind of give soccer
a break and try football and it was a
lot of fun
i was there with a lot of my friends but
i also did you know
plays and i so i was i was one of these
guys who got along with everybody i
wasn't
a jock and i wasn't a drama nerd and i
wasn't you know i
didn't get high but i had stoner friends
i you know so
i really was someone who was kind of
born to be a diplomat
here this is freshman year in high
school so number one thing on my mind
is just like women you know i'm going
through puberty i remember i was in some
classes there was one girl who was a
a year older than me in this class and i
swear to god like i thought she was
so hot and i remember i would kind of
like lean back
and try and catch an angle like we were
like the rows you know the rows were all
set up so
it's like you know like this so i was
probably in row
four and she was like in row two but
kind of around the same
like uh location up and down so i
remember like lean back to try and get a
glance of just like she was just
blossoming and she was
beautiful i don't think she knew who i
was or anything but did you have like
any game like were you
able to talk to these girls at all or no
game
and that's the thing i was a nice guy
but i was very shy i was the guy who and
that's that's part of the problem is
a couple of my friends i'm still close
friends with they had major games so
these guys were like
hooking up with girls left and right and
these were my my closest friends
and i was just like oh wow that seems
pretty cool
but but i was i was a funny guy i was a
you know
relatively popular guy but i just i
remember a junior high school
when our yearbooks were being signed a
lot of the girls
would sign oh my god you're the nicest
guy you're going to be the best dad one
day
that's dad how about like let's you know
let's hook up so yeah
yeah no no high school boy wants to be
told like
you're going to be a great dad someday
horrible
absolutely and i think you know a lot of
it was i was
i was embarrassed i was shy and then i
think also like you know i don't know
what i don't know again if it's an
immigrant thing or not but but
my parents never had a talk with me
birds and bees none of that stuff ever
happened
did you feel like you and your parents
had a
culture clash at that time
absolutely and all the time i mean they
they still look they're
again a lot of immigrant communities and
i'll say this
indian asian uh you know nigerian
iranian a lot of immigrant communities
really
they instill um a
a a certain level of respect for your
elders
and i've said this before too where i
think america
in america you're taught rebel against
your elders
you know mom says something you know
[ __ ] you dad you know whatever you do
that
we could i mean that would be like i
might as well just commit suicide
so yeah there was a lot of like respect
to your parents respect your parents but
at this age i'm sure there was times
that we were first of all from just
wanting to be an actor and do plays and
stuff like i think my parents didn't
want me to do that
but i was good at it and and they kept
they would come and support it but they
wouldn't understand it like the teachers
would say things like hey your kids got
potential to do this for profession and
they'd be like oh great then they get in
the car they'd be like that [ __ ] is
crazy don't listen to her
you're gonna be a doctor my dad's cuban
my mom's like a white
italian lady and we definitely got into
like
american kid like you guys don't
understand me
like that kind of stuff and it
embarrasses me it's one of the things
that like
truly i hold with me that i'm like i
can't believe i acted like that
it makes me so sad and i'm always like
trying to make up for it with my parents
now to be like hey you guys know that i
respect you so much
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast is
brought to you
by mint mobile breaking up with your old
wireless provider just got a whole lot
easier thanks to mint mobile they were
the first company to sell premium
wireless
online only and now mint mobile is
introducing their
unlimited data plan for just 30 bucks a
month
let that sink in an unlimited plan
for 30 bucks how much is your soon to be
ex wireless provider charging you hmm i
bet it's more
i bet it's more for people who hate
their phone bill and are ready to cut
ties with big wireless mint mobile
offers their premium unlimited service
for just you heard it once you're gonna
hear it again
30 bucks a month by going online only
and eliminating
and unlimited unlimited eliminating the
traditional cost of retail
mint of mobile passes significant
savings onto you
my beloved listeners all plans come with
unlimited talk and text and high-speed
data delivered to the nation's
largest 5g network use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan and keep your
same phone number along with all
of your existing contacts and if you're
not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day
money back gear ran t break up this big
wireless and switch to mint mobile's
premium unlimited data plan for
30 bucks a month to get your new
unlimited wireless plan for just 30
bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmogul.com
teen self that's mint mobile dot com
slash
team cut your unlimited wireless bill to
30 bucks a month at mintmobile.com
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast is
brought to you
by purple you know this ad you
love this ad throw some betting on a
bunch of different mattresses and sure
they all look the same the same goes for
pillows but peel away the layers
look at what's inside and you'll see
that they are not all created
equal and that's what makes every purple
pillow and mattress unlike anything
you've ever slept on the purple grid
sets the purple mattress apart from
every other mattress it's a patented
comfort technology
that instantly adapts to your body's
natural shape and sleep style
with over 1 800 open air channels
designed to neutralize body heat purple
provides a cooling effect
other mattresses can't replicate and
this cutting edge technology doesn't
stop with mattresses
every purple pillow is engineered with
the grid for total
head and neck support and absolute
airflow so you're always
on the cool side of the pillow i'm gonna
stay away from talking about my sweat
issues um today and just talk about how
cool the actual purple grid
is um purple actually sent me a little
sample
of the grid and it's really squishy and
i use it as like a little stress
reliever
so uh you know i don't i don't know if
you've been if any of you have
turned on a turn on a news channel but
there's some stress
stress out there in the world but the
purple grid
it it just it just eliminates it it just
eliminates it because purple's
proprietary technology
has been innovating comfort for over
15 years and you can try every purple
product risk-free with free shipping and
returns and purple has financing
available as low as zero 0
apr for qualified customers
experience the purple grid and you'll
sleep like never before
go to purple.com teen self 10
and use promo code teen self 10 that's
teen self and then the number 10
for a limited time and you'll get 10 off
any order of
200 or more that's purple.com
teen self 10 promo code teen self 10 for
off any order of 200 or more
terms apply
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast is brought to you
by
trivia star don't you miss trivia nights
those used to be so fun but guess what
you can bring trivia night right into
your
own home with trivia star trivia star is
a free mobile quiz game that's
entertaining and
challenging you can choose categories
like music sports movies tv
animals celebrities there are over 60
categories to choose from so there's
always more trivia to explore unlike
trivia night which eventually ends with
some drunk guy
getting really mad because he disagrees
with
what the person who's in charge is
saying you don't need to have any of
that
okay you can just play trivia star if
you choose the correct answer for
multiple choices and beat the clock
you move on to the next level it's that
simple no angry drunk guy
the questions get harder over time but
if you get stuck don't
worry because you can use coins and gems
to get a hint
to beat the next level again
trivia night you're not getting coins
and gems okay but trivia star
you are and trivia star has over two
thousand
five star reviews in the apple store
join them today and see if you
are smart enough to win which i know
that you are because you've been
listening to this
podcast and you are an open-hearted and
open-minded person
so right now trivia star is offering you
2500 coins and 500 gems when you
download and play
just go to app the apple or google store
and search trivia star
very simple use your usual searching
skills
again search trivia star and enjoy 2500
coins and 500 gems download trivia star
for free today
listen it's it's a brain development
thing and i see my son now who's 12
kind of talking back a little bit and i
and again
having read books about kids and their
development and all that stuff
i try to be a little more patient and i
try to
once he's a little more calm i go in
there and i talk to him and he always
goes yeah you know i'm right you're
right i you know i kind of acted out
blah blah blah and and the hope is
i guess eventually for them to see it
but it's an
age-old thing that your mind
doesn't see it the way an adult mind's
going to say because a lot of these same
people that butt heads
in their early teens with their parents
they grow up and become best parents
with
best friends with their parents oh yeah
hanging out with them
yeah i mean i have a great relationship
with my parents now but at that time it
was
so explosive and intense
and just like uh but so did you
get into any like real trouble at all or
did your parents like it worked you
towed the line
you know it's funny you say that because
i was talking to my son about this the
other day
and i'm trying to similar to parents i'm
trying to talk to them
talk to him about his respect for his
teachers as well as
my daughter and i'm saying look you're
on zoom now and i know it can be
very uh tedious and
you might be bored and you might blurt
something out and i said just sometimes
think about the teacher they're on the
other end
trying to hold this together and they
want the best for you so i'm trying to
get my son to think about his teacher
before he blurts anything out and i said
i said if you have some kind of
question or something you want to say to
the teacher wait and then during the
office hours you can go one on one
because that teacher also has an ego
well i as a kid got in trouble a couple
of times
for being too talkative in class
blurting things out trying to be
funny there was a couple teachers that i
just didn't really get along with so
i'd be saying things and get sent to the
sent to the um to the office i remember
being
in the office in junior high school with
my mom and my mom had brought my
uncle um my my my mom's sister had
married an american man
and so his english was very good and so
he showed up with my mom and they sat
with me with the principal and it was
like what's going on what's
why are you acting out like this because
i was generally a good kid i was a
polite kid
i was super polite like again i think
this is part of what was instilled in me
as a child but i took it
to the the farthest level you could is
is like if i came to someone's house
even my friends
i would show up and i'd stop at the at
the front door
and they would walk in and say what are
you doing i said can i come in they say
yeah come on
what are you doing and then i go inside
and i stand by the couch what's going on
can i sit
yeah have a seat like i was like a dog
those are like the rules that a vampire
has to live by like they have to
ask if they can come in
do you remember like what when you were
engaging in your
class clownery or whatever do you was it
mostly just like
yelling something out to make a comment
or were you like into pranks at all
i think it was more the yelling stuff
out i wasn't into pranks but i was
always into
being kind of a class clown saying funny
things you know i also fell in love with
eddie murphy at that age like around the
time he
uh i was 10 and he was big and so i was
watching a lot of
stand up and saturday live and all that
stuff so i liked comedy a lot and so i'm
sure there were times in class
that i just you know had a comeback and
the teacher probably at a certain point
would say
you know uh jobrani or maziar that was
my full name is maziar maziar you know
you better
one more warning you know i'd be like
all right then i'd probably look at my
other couple friends who were also
funny ones and then you know just be
raring to do
one more like just let me get one more
in and so
yeah it's it's uh it's interesting
because like i said
i i try to whenever my my wife gets
upset at my son nowadays i just
i remind her i go look i was a really
good kid and i couldn't help
but get a little bit of trouble i had to
you know because i also had some friends
i had some of my close friends who were
going
far like it started with
you know you'd be hanging out with your
buddies and we were like during the
during fourth of july it was oh we're
gonna light some fireworks well the
fireworks at that point was go get some
m80s which is like a quarter stick of
dynamite get some m80s
from chinatown and then we would do a
thing where my friend would hold it i
would light it and he would throw it
now idea is to get it to blow up on you
know in the air
going so of course you could blow out
your fingers as well yeah
but but those friends some of those
friends
they just kept spiraling so it was from
that to then they were hanging out with
like
kids and getting stoned and then they
were like going deeper and then they
were like getting in fights and getting
expelled like
i think the thing that saved me was i
did not get into drugs like i wasn't
into smoking any weed or anything i just
didn't like smoking at all
um and i would drink my father drank
my mom would drink casually my father
actually was kind of a functioning
alcoholic but
like i think at the age of like whatever
was 14 or 15 me and my buddies would
have somebody buy alcohol we'd get drunk
you know you'd throw up sometimes yeah
but it wasn't like oh i have to have it
and it didn't get me into a situation
where i was you know making a deal on a
corner with somebody to get some
weed or whatever that was with coke or
whatever you know
yeah and it seems like you had a lot of
other
activities and stuff going on in your
life like
um we have a football picture you're
saying you also played soccer
and then maybe you were more into soccer
yeah so freshman year i did football
then the rest of my high school career i
did soccer we had a really good soccer
team we went to like the northern
california championships it was just it
was so much fun
it was it's my sport i mean in my life
i've always loved soccer and then
i also played baseball so it would be
fall soccer spring baseball and then in
the summer you'd train for the soccer
again and then in between all that i was
also
in theater um i was trying to be a good
student
as much as i could i was good at math
um yeah i'd be right i had a lot of
activities i i like to go to baseball
games i
i would you know i stayed pretty busy
what plays did you do
do you remember like the first part that
you did
that gave you like the bug to perform
well first of all going back to all the
activities i also would have summer jobs
i never sat around i was always doing
something so i was
you know always active um the first play
i did
junior high school seventh grade it was
the musical the boyfriend
and i don't know why i auditioned for it
you know the boyfriend you don't know i
don't there's some one of the songs that
goes won't you
charleston with me but i want you
justin with me if you see it the
charleston is a famous song like the 20s
charleston yeah
audition for that and i'm not sure what
got me to audition for it i don't know
if it was like
my friends wanted to do it or like some
of the girls i was attracted to were
doing it or i just wanted to try it
this is seventh grade i'm pretty sure
there was something there where they
were saying we need boys so just
come on out you know okay that's always
how it works for the boys and then for
the girls we were like [ __ ] mud
wrestling each other for these parts
like tearing each other's hair out
hilarious the boys want to do it so
i got in and i was you know background
dancer or whatever
and so the ladies the lady the director
her name was shirley bonbright and
shirley brownbright was
a volunteer she was directing and she
told that she said
when you're doing a musical when you're
on stage singing and dancing in the
background you need to always be smiling
and you know and be dancing right so
again as a good immigrant kid
i took that to heart i was like shirley
said you know she's authority she said
smile so i'm gonna smile
and again of course my american
rebellious
friends were probably like whatever you
know so they were just like out there
doing their thing
so one day uh in seventh grade
i was sick i was under the weather but i
went to rehearsals because i knew it was
important to be
be there because i also instilled that
in you so i showed up hi ms bomb bright
i'm here today a little under the
weather but i'm going to get through it
oh thank you for coming great so now i'm
on stage
singing and dancing she stops the whole
rehearsal stop everybody stop
stop what's going on look at him look at
him he's sick
and he came and he's smiling and he's
dancing he said i'll learn from him and
i'm like oh yeah you should
so he has what it takes to make it on
broadway
so it was a moment of whoa and then
i think they gave me like a couple of
extra lines in the play and i felt good
about it and that's cool
so next year eighth grade i did uh it
was little abner and i i was little
abner
and i actually have the video of that
somewhere um
yeah so that was a blast i had fun then
i go to my high school
which um redwood high school had a a
theater company called the ensemble
theater company it was between redwood
drake and tam those are the three high
schools of that
uh but they had the ensemble theater
company there was a lady her name was uh
michelle swanson who ran the ensemble
theater company as a matter of fact i've
connected with her later in life
oh that's amazing yeah i hooked up on
tour recently saw her
in in portland um but that was like that
was a real
theater company where they taught um you
know breaking down your script and the
meisner method and this and then
improv and so i did it sophomore year
junior
senior year um she was yet another one
of the teachers who said you can do this
professionally and i didn't even know
what that meant
um and then we would do what was great
about the etc the ensemble theater
company
it was they had the kids
quite often write produce do the tech
everything so i just remember being in
all these one-act plays that were
written by the
other kids and i remember doing the test
it was that was a great experience
did you gravitate like when there was
the opportunity did you gravitate
towards
comedic roles and doing comedy
in that or was
were you like i'm a straight actor
no i think it was the former um i also
loved
doing the straight actor but uh but
having been a
fan of eddie murphy and all these comedy
people and wanted to actually i wanted
to get to
snl at that point i was like i want to
be because eddie got into snl at the age
of 19 i said i want to get the snl
younger and perhaps i would have pursued
it actually if my
parents had been of the mind of like go
for it but they were like no you need to
do something else and so i took a
detour and didn't really pursue comedy
and acting professionally until i was 26
but
you know like you look at a guy like i
mean like i said rob willis went to the
same high school
you know he was so amazing as a comedic
actor but you will look at someone like
that if you want to be inspired by them
and go wow look at how great he is as a
dramatic actor so you wanted a chance to
do both
and i continue to have that desire do
you ever look back like i always
i look back on a lot of my high school
shows
and especially the ones where we like
really tried to tackle like
you know intense material like your
animal cruelty play
i remember feeling at that time that i
was like
we are so good and i would love to be
able to objectively go back
and watch and see like what the actual
skill level was that was happening there
well i think that you hit a certain age
whether it's like sophomore junior
senior
where some real talented people start to
pop
and and i i say that having gone back
years ago i was doing some play in la
and we needed a theater and so we went
to the beverly hills high school theater
to see what it looked like and they said
why don't you come
watch this current play we have going
and then you guys can see what
what it looks like when it's lit up and
everything so sure we show up and this
production was amazing and people were
dancing and their legs were kicking high
and they were all in line and the acting
and i go whoa
and so we all know i mean
i think the difference between stand-up
comedy and and
singing for sure and also probably
acting
somewhat stand-up comedy you really have
to put in the years
you very rarely find a young stand-up
comic
who has a point of view that's very
clear
has has their writing down and is saying
something it really takes
five to ten years with your voice you
could have just a beautiful voice and
i've seen it now we see it now all the
time on social media people
you know jamming with a song you go whoa
how old is this person
and with acting sometimes the
lesser experienced actors are more
uninhibited and that's what you need you
know inhibition's the enemy of acting
so um i i
have been uh i think that if you went
back and saw those productions you would
see some
some sparks of wow that's pretty good
but obviously there's also look in it
on broadway you have 100 people who all
want to be
actors in your school play you have
three people that want to be actors you
know three that are like
they're all right and then the rest is
just like oh i just did this for fun and
then i can yeah
or like there's a girl here that i think
is a cute girl or vice versa
exactly exactly we've got two more
photos of you and i would love to go
through them before we round
everything out is this this photo you
are dressed as batman
are we in a play here yeah so this was
our
senior class play as i said the
the it's a musical uh written uh
composed
all the above by the students and it was
batman the musical
and i got to play batman and i was a
senior and
it's funny because sometimes when i talk
about
coming to hollywood as an as a middle
eastern american actor i go you know in
high school i got to play batman i was
little abner i got to play all these
things and in my mind i go
i'm going to go to hollywood and be
batman and you thought they're like
no you're not going to be batman um you
know put on a turban
um so it's a good awakening
um but but this was yes so this was so
the play
actually the the main character was
robin in this play
but i played obviously psychic batman
and
again there were songs uh catwoman was
played by chyna kantner who
is grace slick's daughter from jefferson
airplane oh
um yeah so she lived in marin um
and it was i still have songs the the
theme song it went
i love gotham city there's excitement in
the air
i love city there's excitement
everywhere
sorry i still have that in my head 30
years later
i have to ask were you dating the
theater girls because i feel like if
you're starring in these plays
you're doing sports you've got great
hair
you would have been cl and as far as the
oakton high school theater program
is concerned you would have been
cleaning up so i have to ask
well my son just came in to take his
bike
zoom buddy get out of here go go
where you going okay can you close the
door please and that light just changed
for me close the door
there it is so i will answer you um
no i was not dating the theater girls
and
you know again i think my lack of game
i don't know i look back on those years
and i think what you just said i go god
i
i was a star of little abner i i
probably could have made a move i didn't
make any moves
and i i wasn't actually i didn't start
i didn't have an actual girlfriend until
uh i think it was
summer of junior year going into senior
year
and i uh met this with this girl who
she also played soccer i played soccer
she was newer to the school
and we hit it off and then we just
started dating but she wasn't one of the
theater girls and
and i had crushes on some of the theater
girls but again i just
i don't know why i never made like that
you know there was a lot of like
looking back on it there was a lot of
times of like whatever we would have
i don't know dance-a-thon or something
you know there was a dance-a-thon where
we were raising money by dancing for
hours and hours
and i'm sure there was moments of that
dance-a-thon where it was like oh let's
get a little uh massage train going and
you're
either you're massaging the girl that
you have a crush on or she's massaging
you and she's giving you hints if you're
just like okay whatever all right
you know so many massage trains in high
school theater
so many we've got one more photo for you
and i think it's actually the perfect
thing for me to pull up
as i ask our last question because you
really do look
very sweet and precious in this photo um
i'm assuming this is your senior
yearbook photo
yeah senior yearbook photo you gotta
wear you know tie you gotta
look like uh gentlemen as you can see
you got that scarf you look at that
scarf speaking of
cubans and scarface that scar on the um
i guess if you're looking at it would be
that it's a left cheek
uh that was i guess when i was like two
years older so i saw my dad
shaving so i liked it i wanted to try
and shave so i took a razor and it
cut my skin and so i've had that my
whole life oh my god
yeah pretty crazy right yeah but it's
it's like
um i feel like it's one of those
interesting scars like
i mean it makes it look like you got in
a cool fight and not that you just
accidentally shave listen my whole thing
is
it's like just live with what you have i
i know like i named you know when you
when you get into uh um
hollywood and you're acting and all this
stuff at a certain point you incorporate
a lot of people
that might be listening don't know this
but you get a corporation so that when
they
when you do a show they don't pay you as
much your money they pay you as your
corporation yes
um tax purposes so the uh
you got to come up with a name right and
people go jobrani limited or whatever it
is and i i came up my name for my
corporation was
perfect nose productions those being the
nose
and the reason was i thought to myself
at that point when i was incorporating i
was older obviously i thought you know
what you have
and what's kind of been given to you is
perfect like learn to love what you have
so this nose of mine
is perfect my grandfather had a bumpy
nose it was perfect my dad had a bumpy
nose
it was perfect and similarly with these
scars you know obviously
there are extreme situations where
someone says my god i've got whatever
a really bad situation that i need to go
get
you know fixed through plastic surgery
or what have you but i just feel that
more and more people go into this world
of
plastic surgery and botox and hair plugs
and blah blah blah
and i feel that what's detrimental is
that it doesn't
force them to work on themselves
as people and improve themselves as
people but rather just what they see
and so when i see that scar as you said
it's a story it's part of me
so i would not touch it
that's beautiful and we like to we end
every uh episode of the podcast uh
i like to ask if you could talk
to teen moms today what would you tell
him
if i could talk to teen monster i would
say you know what
uh go go uh
pursue the acting stuff go for your
heart like go
i mean one thing i try not to do is
never have regrets because the fact is
those years from high school until the
year
the years i decided to do this
professionally
i had amazing experiences i went to
college i went to uc berkeley i love uc
berkeley i went to italy to study abroad
one of the best years of my life i made
some friends etc etc
however there's an adventurous part of
me that thinks what would have happened
i almost
you know i got into nyu coming out of uh
high school
just in as a uh like uh
in the business program or something it
wasn't in the theater program i actually
heard aziz ansari talk about something
very similar
and i thought to myself i almost went to
nyu with the intention of going there
and then starting to do plays and
whatever so
back in my mind i wonder what would have
happened if i would have pursued that
and been in that world right away
again i'd be giving up a lot of stuff
that i don't give up
i don't want to give up yeah but it's
it's a tough choice
but i would say to that guy i'd say go
for it don't be don't be
i mean i i've now anytime i give advice
to young people i say
you live one life so live for yourself
don't live to impress your parents don't
live to impress
your girlfriend your boyfriend your
whatever it is
if you [ __ ] if you're lucky enough to
have found a passion
then go for it and i would say that to
this guy go clean up with the theater
girls they probably have a crush on you
come on dude
get some oh my this was such a great
episode it was amazing
to talk to you and it was just a delight
to have you on the podcast thank you so
much
thank you for having me claudia i mean
because i know that i gotta send her the
thing and i was about to ask her
i introduced you with a podcast from 10
years ago so it's it's literally fine
we've gotta get a wikipedia it's going
to list you as claudia
all right and for everyone at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
you